herzlich willkommen auf dem kanal vom
achtung spoiler raum gehen wir nach
gewinner geteilter gewinner ihr habt
vielleicht gesehen ich war beim
perfekten promi dinner dabei und habe
ein menü präsentiert sich heute im
detail präsentieren möchte es ist sehr
vielfältig das ist das meiste was ich
mir mit meinem aktuellen können stamm
zugetraut habe für so einen tag wie
diesen und ich werde nebenbei auch noch
ein bisschen erzählen wie war das für
mich was ging da ab wie wurde das ganze
bearbeitet und wie geht überhaupt damit
dass sie einfach im fernsehen war sich
das ist wahrscheinlich für mich ähnlich
verrückt ich für euch dass man einfach
so seine videos macht und irgendwann
glaubt das fernsehen an und sagt so echt
bist du nicht beim perfekten promi
dinner mitmachen und ihren dem ich das
erzählt er
wir fangen an mit dem gruß aus der küche
den ich als einzige gast gereicht habe
ich habe es ganz einfach gehalten ich
habe mir so ein stanza geholt habe aus
einem in dem fall italienischen brot das
ist jetzt ein in anführungszeichen
normales verschiedene kreise ausgestanzt
habe die dann an gerüstet in der pfanne
mit ein bisschen olivenöl und erste
frage wie kommt man auf ein menü welches
man bei so einem event präsentiert ich
bin im kopf durchgegangen das ist das
beste was ich je gegessen habe was ist
das leckerste was ich selbst gekocht
habe und wie kriege ich das irgendwie
zusammen gruß aus der küche ist ja im
prinzip einfach nur eine fancy version
von all dem was wir schon häufig gemacht
so schön geröstetes brot dorada
selbstgemachtes pesto eine konzerte
tomate punkt wer ist es nicht mehr
brauchen wir auch nicht dafür nehme ich
sowieso nicht bewertet also es wurde
extra gesagt das würde nicht
berücksichtigt ich wollte es trotzdem
machen weil ich habe in meinem menü das
thema italien durch nicht mag ich sehr
gerne die italienische küche und habe
mir gedacht irgendwie muss ich das da
reinbringen habe das dann auf die art
und weise gemacht keine ahnung ich bin
happy dass es gemacht habe auch wenn es
mir keine punkte geben das weiß ich
jetzt einmal an wir wollten halt ganz
gerne einfach die leute so kulinarisch
einstimmen so dass es zur italienischen
dass es besser wird und wo es einfach
hingehen sollte ich mache ein bisschen
öl über unsere tomaten und gebe die
einfach mit ein bisschen öl in den
backofen
es war alles in allem sehr skurrile
erfahrungen müsst wissen leute das ist
nicht einfach nur ein bisschen kochen
sondern ihr habt eine vielzahl von
realisator
kameramännern leuten die die ordner
machen make up artist alle sind immer da
trotzdem müsste sie eigentlich
ausblenden deshalb es war gar nicht mal
so leicht ich war im endeffekt zufrieden
damit wie ich das ganze gehandelt habe
und so aber es ist auf jeden fall nicht
so wie normaler videodreh wo so eric so
mein promi hinterlegt morgen bei meinen
kollegen hinter der kamera ist auf jeden
fall noch ein ganz anderer schnack aber
eric hat er auch seinen auftritt mit als
jemand der von a bis z so die zügel in
der hand hat bei seinem youtube kanal
und man auch immer so die sorge sowie
stellen die mich da was machen die mit
mir und so aber so viel kann ich sagen
dass ich es nicht gesehen habt denn
eigentlich ganz gut davon gekommen aber
von mir wurde halt wirklich nur es gab
so viel macht ja nur immer so dieses
klubs scheiße rische gezeigt also das
polizeiboot es über essen so
philosophiert haare so wisst ihr wie
beim probieren so sowie zeit immer mache
weil ich halte sehr konzentriert
schnecke und wie auch immer abseits
davon bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden
also gar nicht so vielseitig aber die
haben uns alle unsere rollen gegeben ist
mit dabei waren kevin papa platte mal
wanne und lara of kevin wahr so der
verstrahlte einfach mal wanne war sie
diejenige die so anders war aber
trotzdem genau wusste dass die macht
will und ich war so der der klugscheißer
von kevin herrmann einfach kennen
einfach so lost fanny so wie wir ihn
kennen heute kommen wir das alles noch
mal neu vielleicht wenn ich auch das
eine oder andere feedback an was sie von
meinen gästen bekommen habe und das hier
ist alles was wir dafür brauchen das ist
die vielfalt von produkten und bin mir
sicher das wird nicht es ist schon genug
nehme ich das ganze mal raus dann
wichtig hier einmal durch die halle
durch was denn da will ich jetzt ganz so
pastor die pinienkerne an dann nehme ich
natürlich fünf mark für die interne
konkurrenz
sich einmal durch und wie man feste
macht habe ich schon ganz oft gezeigt
wisst ihr wahrscheinlich auch selbst
deshalb haben wir das ganze schnell
[Musik]
oder hätte ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
parmesan unter dann ist unser fest so
fertigte gesagt jetzt schon ganz aus
gesehen ist ja doch keine toxischen
damit kann man jedes herz gewinn habe
ich ja zumindest besser habe ich direkt
zu beheben gemacht war etwa 20 minuten
sind auch unsere crew mädchen praktisch
wenn diese leicht aufplatzen ist das
absolut das was wir erreichen wollen ach
die haben die berater die tomaten wir
haben pastor und wir können anfangen
unseren gruß aus der küche
zusammenzubauen geht ganz einfach
bezogen dann unsere berater wissen was
abrate einfach ungeschlagen so cremig
weil das herz begehrt ein wenig ins und
selbstgemachten pesto die farben daran
erkennt zu so würde niemals gekauft es
aussehen so grün geht das nur wenn es
vor fünf android-plattform waren
verbrennen wir uns die hände über eine
tomate zu nehmen oben drauf und schon
ist unser großer aus der küche fertig
ich habe in dem moment hatte ich erst
mal alle in der tasche weil auto das ist
wirklich sehr sehr stabil das ist aber
auch das einfachste was sie an dem tag
gemacht habe deshalb habe ich da nicht
zu viel drauf gegeben die anderen haben
auch in der folge dann in den interviews
gesagt dass ich das sehr lecker fand es
ist wirklich auch sehr lecker aber schon
bei der vorspeise wird jetzt richtig
kritisch willkommen zu unserer vorspeise
drei hauptkomponenten salat
jakobsmuschel und ein computer tomate
der rote faden ihr wisst bescheid wir
nehmen hat rote zwiebeln dünn
geschnitten eben darauf ein bisschen von
all diesen guten zeug das heißt ein
wenig olivenöl ahornsirup ein stückchen
balsamico und apfelessig dann
verstand eric da in der folge so dass
wir das ganze kurz marinieren ich gebe
strom öl zum frittieren in unseren top
sind flächen brauchen wir auf jeden fall
schon dann kann man jetzt auch unsere
romaner salatherzen teilen wir der
hälfte offenbaren sie ihre wunderschönen
sehr schöne exemplare und kombinaten die
erste richtige die noch erde so sand
drin hatten
gleichmäßig verteilen damit ohne alles
weitere gehen jetzt im ersten
kurzen zeit gucken wir uns das ganze
immer an es soll schon reichen ihr fragt
euch oder man fragt sich vielleicht baum
dreht man salat an den ganz einfachen
hintergrund leicht wenn man dran riecht
jetzt das hat somit zusätzliche
dimension hier dieser rat eigentlich
nicht kapieren auf der außenseite immer
noch ganz normal knusprig ist dann
schneiden wir unten den strom ab sagt
nicht zu hoch weil sonst hätte er nicht
mehr zusammen dann schneidet runden so
was wie so eine ebene auf dem das ganze
stehen kann hinein so haben wir dann
unsere salatherzen oder salate filets
angegrillt jetzt machen wir eben unsere
salatsauce wir nehmen den grundbaustein
eine rostet smi soße dies auch der
geschmacksträger der vorspeise gar keine
frage und gepimpten die ein bisschen auf
jeden fall millimeter oder zitrone
irgendeiner form auf jeden fall noch
eine leichte zitrusnoten press und davon
auch noch ein bisschen was zu unserem
dressing ein wenig honig salz pfeffer
und jetzt nehmen wir uns von dem
dressing und streichen das tief in die
verschiedenen schichten des romaner
salat und merkt dass zieht wirklich
darin ein der verteilt sich im komitee
nacht habe ich den salat klein
geschnitten und quasi wie normalen
fahrrad hin dass selbst bringen so einen
kleinen häufchen angerichtet dass ich
auch persönlich sehr sehr nice brand
aber ich habe das gefühl dass dadurch
dass ich ihn so angerichtet habe so ein
bisschen auf der strecke geblieben ist
dass ich ihn halt angegrillt habe und so
diese optik mit diesen dunklen stellen
und so kam nicht so wirklich zu tragen
das sage ich das ganze jetzt so mache
weiter zu erwähnen ich weder mit voller
punkte noch alleine gewonnen habe selbst
auf jeden fall noch raum für
verbesserungen
damit es auch schon zeit für unsere jara
posselt sie frittieren wir jetzt und
dann richten
[Musik]
sie sind 500 daten der küche aber die
vorspeise ist fertig so finde ich sie
auf jeden fall hübscher als in der schau
wir wollen einfach mal rein einfach mal
anschneiden mehr dressing jakobsmuschel
[Musik]
müsst wissen erikson meine überlegung
war dass wir ein menü konzipieren wo
alles von der geschmacksintensität her
wie staat es schmeckt und die interviews
schmeckte 10 ist das ist durch dieses
sesam dressing was er wirklich so
kraftvoll moden ds 100 prozent gegeben
wir haben in den zwischenräumen das
dressing gibt schreibt wir haben die
intensive flambierte jakobsmuschel aber
ich kann es nachvollziehen warum es in
der form die in der show seine zehn
zehen war so kommt es gefährlich nah
dran frisch geschmackvoll also mehr
diesen knapp geraten einfach und knacken
genau knacken seit es war so ist der
beste freundin nicht aufzuschneiden ich
würde sagen mit dieser gabe jetzt weiter
zum hauptgericht für unsere hauptspeise
bereit und der zweifachen vornehmlich
eine rosmarin butter und kräuter
seidling kroos marin butter das rezept
ist der name gegeben in eine pfanne
butter und wir ziehen uns ein wenig groß
marin vom spiel ab wo ich ordentlich das
war eine sache die ich sehr gemocht habe
zumindest aber auch nicht selbst
überlegt sondern maximilian lorenz unser
alter freund hat das auf seiner karte
stehen ab und ich sage so viel das ist
so krass und kommt zudem eric hat allen
voran da noch über das von beschwert die
ganze zeit denn ehrlich was macht ein
rezept wutbürger 7000 auch gelernt bei
maximilian lorenz also unsere wut
journey so diese ganze reise die wir
letzten jahre der letzten anderen vier
jahren erlebt haben hat er auf jeden
fall den grundstein gelegt für alles was
wir da gemacht habe weil ich sagen
ehrlich vor eineinhalb jahren habe ich
hier noch nicht so wirklich bekommt der
anderen fahrer machen wir schon ein
bisschen olivenöl heißen schnappen wir
uns unsere treuchtlingen schneiden die
viertel erstmal und paten erhalten nur
ein bisschen groß marie mutter ist schon
mal fertig dann können wir uns
eigentlich schon ein pop nehmen für
unsere poland abgegeben wir 800
milliliter flüssigkeit 400 milliliter
sahne und 100 milliliter milch in einen
topf und kochen das ganze einmal leicht
auf dann baut direkt die banner aus
bioshock 2 120 daten für schnittler
fertig sind unsere
irgendwer das ganze gespräch ist die
kamera zu liefern wo die anderen drin
wir uns immer sagen würde ich nochmal
ein ganz anderer schlagsahne mit kochen
auf das heißt es wird zeit für unsere
polenta dass jetzt 100 gramm instant
polenta die gebe ich jetzt um braucht
macht den herd aus und beginnen jetzt
kontinuierlich
rührend und das ganze hin zu tun da
könnt ihr dann nach belieben je nachdem
wie fest ihr es haben wollte sind mehr
oder weniger nehmen jetzt angefangen mit
100 gramm polenta 800 milliliter
flüssigkeit muss man sich einfach
ausprobieren so diese konsistenz haben
jetzt erreicht deutlich standhafter als
ich in der show hatte weil das wetter zu
teilen zu kritik geführt jetzt geben wir
die rosmarin butter oben drüber die wird
richtig schön schlapp traurig sind darf
safenet geile muss karten und haben
polenta
ratings mich bemüht entdeckt und die
idee das sage ich euch bei einer reise
in einem land vor unserer zeit also
wirklich lange lange vor diesen dreh
habe ich hab's gemacht angeröstet ich
habe dazu zwiebeln carport und neuen
säle ebenfalls mit angedeuteten ich habe
wein drauf das wird ein halb liter brühe
wasser kochen lassen über nacht stehen
gelassen das feld oben abgehoben durch
ein tuch passiert und im kühlschrank
aushärten lassen das resultat eine jury
die wirklich stolz in mir hervorgerufen
hat ich werde euch gleich präsentiert
ein paar tropfen auf das fertige gericht
aber viel viel arbeit und das potenzial
so ein gericht wirklich aufs nächste
level zu leben hier ist auf jeden fall
unsere die wir zweimal rahmen machen
auch eine gute süd das habe ich gemacht
lorenz genannt zeichnet sich dadurch aus
dass sie so einen leichten glanz hat wie
so ein lack ist bleibt noch eine
komponente das fleisch was habe ich wie
auch in der show sowie gegart einfach
nur um das fehlerpotenzial zu minimieren
und das ganze mit speck umwickelt und
auf dem feld
[Musik]
das ist sie meine hauptspeise und
wirklich auch der star von meinem menü
also nicht umsonst kommt das aus den
füller von einem sternekoch es ist
einfach ein krasses gericht eine krasse
kreation und ich finde sie ist mir
zumindest am abend der show sehr gut
gelungen jetzt müssen wir mal gucken
dann gehen die polenta und probieren
weil die mit ein bisschen crazy
schön cremig otte die rosmarin note in
der polenta ist wirklich eine szene von
10 und auch die entscheidung das ist ein
rahmen palette ist also mit milch und
sahne sehr sehr krass das fleisch
weingutes kalbsfilet so beat gegart mehr
muss man eigentlich nicht sagen dazu
noch ein bisschen beziehungsweise
eigentlich was bronchiale diese seefisch
so kraftvoll wie polenta fungiert fast
wie eine eigene soße durch die
cremigkeit nochmal die mancher der bacon
der anführungszeichen gibt den nötigen
stärke im geschmack dazu weil das
vielleicht als sehr zart ist also das
ist wirklich ein sehr ausgefeiltes
wenn ihr nur eine sache nachkaufen
mit diesem mächtigen hauptgang
wohlschmeckenden hauptgang den magen
verlangt ist noch etwas frischen weil
etwas erfrischendem deshalb wird ein
zitronensorbet und die konter nachspeise
einfach nur ein zitronensorbet wir haben
drei würfeln wir haben wasser wir haben
eier zucker und hier zitronen welche am
main zitronen sind es ist wirklich
wichtig bei denen steht umfeld hält die
qualität des gerichts dessen hat richtig
gute zitronen verwenden und das macht
mir auch so wir schneiden bei den
zitronen um den deckel abgleich holen
wir das ganze hier einfach aus das macht
gerechnet dafür kann man das wäre zum
beispiel schon gar nicht gegangen wird
kaputt wir brauchen die testen also
geben in unseren top das wasser etwa 200
gramm und da hätten wir die ganzen
testen hinein natürlich dafür gewaschen
die zitronen das ganze machen jetzt bei
allen zitronen fruchtfleisch raus und
dann hat
160 gramm zitronensaft 200 gramm 1 150
gramm zucker 200 milliliter wasser
zitronen testen alles rallye ich will
jetzt das wasser mit den zitronen festen
an und während das ganze aufheizt
fröhlich den zucker unter der zucker
löst sich jetzt gleich aufwendig so die
ein gläschen filmen wissen wir das ist
zeit das ganze zu schließen deckel drauf
zehn minuten so gut zuhören soweit diese
gläser so ins erdreich leute zehn
minuten sind vorbei ganze schon ein
bisschen abgekühlt den rest erledigt
unser eis wird die 200 gramm eis können
200 gramm warmes wasser ziemlich genau
perfekt auf raumtemperatur unter
physikern machen wir das ganze auch
können sie das auch die doppelte menge
wasser nehmen uns einfach stehen lassen
aber das geht schneller das machen wir
das ganze soll dann haben wir diesen
wunderbaren weg beschritten wir noch die
160 milliliter pro unser jetzt haben wir
das allerwichtigste von unseren bisher
schon erledigt wenn ihr das nach macht
und ein standmixer hat es mit dem
stabmixer ich habe gerade irgendwie
keinen funktionierenden am start da
gehen jetzt einfach ein eiweiß hinein
wenn das eiweiß steif schlagen jetzt
geben wir nach und nach unsere 4 unter
so sieht das ganze aus ganz fertig ist
wenn man es ihm standmixer macht dann
hat man das in einer einheitlichen masse
die gesagt haben nämlich ließ play
hinten eigens besorgen das ist zwei
container untergrundes und kühl
kompressor sondern den zwischenraum
kommt eine kappe hochprozentiger alkohol
dann kommt die anderen schlüssel wieder
zu sich nehmen unsere mischung und
schütten das könnte hier ein bleibt uns
nur noch in vw kraft zu drücken deckel
druck der rest erledigt sich von selbst
die wahre kunst liegt dann gleich oder
in der stunde im anrichten jetzt müssen
wir noch anrichten das ist sehr schön
geworden also es ist wirklich bildhübsch
wenn ich jetzt eine spritze biete und
befüllen sie mit dem song
nicht ganz bis oben sondern nur so zum
teil und dann das habe ich in der ganzen
aufregung vergessen wollte ich noch so
12 - plättchen einfach fürs auge so
kommt das ganze dann an den platz
ist so kalt wie es hier gerade recht
meinst du von der zitrone dann wird am
platz der decke abgehoben und wie gießen
mit prosecco auf am besten ohne dass es
über schäumt das habe ich zum glück in
der show geschafft bevor ich das ganze
jetzt probiere ich habe auch in der show
wie gesagt hätte er gewonnen so ich habe
schon spoiler warning am anfang an dem
ich habe 5000 euro gewonnen ich eine
gemeinnützige organisation spenden
konnte und ich habe mich entschieden
dass dann die mtfs forschung zu spenden
jetzt habe ich jetzt auch mal kurz
darauf eingehen möchte mfs das ist ein
relativ unerforscht krankheit bei der du
einfach von jetzt auf gleich aus seinem
leben ausgerissen werden kannst kann
passieren dass ein mensch wie du und ich
einfach jetzt auf gleich am nächsten tag
einfach unerklärliche crashes er leidet
die es ihm einfach unmöglich machen aus
dem bett aufzustehen sich anzustrengen
irgendwas zu machen und dieses schicksal
hat ein freund von mir alt und umso
krasser finden ist und umso besser
verstehe ich wie heftig und wie schlimm
das ist das ist einfach diese sache die
und dass man aber gleichzeitig nichts
darüber weiß so dass die leute die
darunter leiden nicht so ohnmächtig sind
so dass sie nichts tun können um ihr
schicksal zu verändern dass wir nicht
wissen endlich mal jetzt das und dann
geht es mir wieder gut so deshalb habe
ich da einen gewinn von 5000 hin
gespendet habe auch selbst spenden
verdoppelten werde euch auch rechnen es
ist eine wichtige sache noch mal ein
paar links in die beschreibung packen wo
ihr euch selbst darüber informieren
können weil wie gesagt ich finde einfach
da passiert viel zu wenig und da sollte
ein viel besseres verständnis
vorherrschen deshalb guckt euch das an
aber jetzt hoffentlich zu schöneren
dingen in eine zitrone von unten auswahl
schenke ich noch ein bisschen prosecco
nach das jetzt hier ungeschönt stehen
dann jetzt nämlich auch nicht dann gehen
wir einfach mal rein roskow
zitronensorbet
also ich finde schon sehr sehr gern so
diese säure vom prosecco und der süße
aber auch gleichzeitig säure kommen
zitronensorbet frische minze kommt auch
nicht verkehrt auf jeden fall peile ich
vielleicht aussetzt getraut und ja das
war auf jeden fall auch noch mal
herzlichen glückwunsch an vanessa einmal
war nimmt mir den geteilten ersten platz
gemacht wird auch ein wirklich wildes
menü gekocht habe mein favorit bei ihre
vorspeise das war sehr sehr lecker
vielen dank an das perfekte promi dinner
dass sie mich überhaupt eingeladen haben
dass sie mich mit einbezogen haben die
planung zwar sehr aufregung zumal im
fernsehen mir zu spielen der eigentliche
drehtag bei mir 14 stunden lang wirklich
das was ganz ganz anderes als meine
kleinen videos hier die ich mit eric
produziere aber eine spannende erfahrung
danke dass sie machen dürfte bis zum
nächsten mal und haut rein cha cha